Kevin Hart stepped down from hosting the
2019 Oscars and it is stirring up
outrage in Hollywood it's a bit of a
mixed bag of emotions but in a shocking
turn of events for Kevin his dream gig
is now up for grabs what a whirlwind 24
hours on Thursday night if you guys
missed it the comedian and actor
announced he was dropping out of his
hosting duties after the Academy asked
him to apologize for past homophobic
tweet so I just got a call from the
Academy and that call basically said
Kevin apologize for your tweets of old
or we're gonna have to move on to final
post it's all about the tweets in
2009-2010 I chose the past I passed on
your pond I'm not gonna do it man I'm
gonna be me I'm gonna stand my ground
regardless Academy I'm thankful and
appreciative of the opportunity if it
goes away no harm no foul ironic Katie
hours after that video where he said he
would not apologize he released a
statement on Twitter doing just that and
dropping out right he wrote in part I do
not want to be a distraction on a night
that should be celebrated by so many
amazing talented artists I sincerely
apologize to the LGBTQ community for my
insensitive words from the past he
should have just apologized from the
get-go and acknowledged he made these
mistakes but their refusal to do so made
him come off in my opinion and I think
we've talked about this yeah so right
[ __ ] yeah he came across a little
self-righteous but my thing is this was
his dream gig so in June is he gonna get
the best of him glad president Sarah
Kate Ellis responded with this writing
Kevin Hart shouldn't have stepped down
he should have stepped up Hart's apology
to LGBTQ people is an important step
forward and he missed a real opportunity
to use his platform and the Oscar stage
to build unity and awareness we would
still welcome that conversation with him
so it seems like it's not completely
done I know Kevin has made his
resignation clear but everyone else
seems to be open to him coming back on
it you know under some conditions you
guys we actually talked to a lot of
celebrities and people who know Kevin
Hart in the Hollywood circle at the GQ
man in Hollywood party last night and
they all weighed in on this controversy
and it sounds like a little messy
and a little sloppy I'm not thrilled
what did you think of the statement he
related a OHS lame yeah it was lame
well I'm disappointed what can I say I'm
disappointed Kevin loved his comedy I
didn't know the facts I didn't know what
this is about
listen I'm just learning this now tank
also took to Instagram in outrage
comparing Kevin's action to the POTUS
writing and caption good people make
mistakes there are so many shady
individuals in this business who deserve
this kind of treatment but keV come on
man at the academy this is not fair and
is not just what do you guys think do
you think someone else should step in
who are your choices Ellen DeGeneres I
think that's a really good pick we also
have Whoopi Goldberg we have Neil
Patrick Harris Chris Rock Jimmy Kimmel
the list goes on all right guys let's
keep the conversation going over on
social let us know who you think could
possibly replace Kevin Hart yep I met
Courtney underscore token ah I'm Katie
underscore crass and I'll see you next
time
[Music]